tonight on inside the music the year was
1978 and the city was the Bronx can get
down brothers a local group that
included a wordsmith name book and a DJ
called Shaolin fantastic we're heading
the rebellion got created a new set down
some thought it might change the game
forever but just remove the pop music
Aiden a young singer named Miley
increase a local group who came from
humble Church begins teamed with her
friends the store Madonna to create a
unique dance tune that was about to
break the charm I
four feet away now on a little for me
her burrow where I'm from
ain't the slum we got King and that's
what I'll be
my friends of me run in the jungle with
the Lions down won't you could cut a
record together sing it to myself should
I take a chance we believe by lean can
become the number one disco artist in
the country
get ready to see her with the world
Ezekiel has a real future and you can't
hear me can you throw away your
reputation Brooke came down with the
next great American musical genre no
doubt gonna be let's see what you like
the namibian by Konami you leave the top
snake don't come back always talking
about breaking free she's only one who
you have no idea what I've done to put
us in a good situation I don't want my
soul on loan we want to get out of the
drug did my leader because she makes the
people think for herself
you have no idea what I am capable of
can get it is telegraphic your time is
not making something on myself and
losing myself then what am I making
then we bought it for life wouldn't turn
out the light we're going to take our
music for minor dementedly
[Music]
you